leftwing groups trying to make it to the
center of Argentina's capital buenos
Idis they came here to protest against
the economic policies of kavier M's new
government for the first time in years
they were met with resistance by
Security Forces Gabriel Solano says m is
trying to remove certain fundamental
rights the government is violating the
right to protest in Argentina they want
to violate the Judiciary and the
legislative branches with a series of
laws they want to pass I am very worried
about Democratic freedoms in
Argentina the police controlled access
to the capital and filmed people on
buses and train stations who were trying
to make it to the center of the city
there's lots of tension in the center of
woid with hundreds of police officers
that have been deployed here the
government says that protesters are not
allowed to cover their faces or to carry
what could be considered a weapon like a
stick they're also saying that
protesters won't be allowed to block any
roads which has been a common practice
until
now despite this demonstrators on foot
managed to reach the plaza de majo in
front of the presidential
Palace Argentina is in the middle of an
economic crisis inflation was already
very high when Javier M took office 10
days ago but a 54% evaluation of the
currency last week has made the
situation even worse mle says only an
orthodox economic plan will get
Argentina out of the crisis
muchas and that's why on Wednesday he
announced a mega decree to reform
thousands of laws on issues like labor
exports State companies and
land the objective is to begin with the
Reconstruction of our country give back
freedom to our individuals and begin to
dismantle the enormous quantity of
regulations that have stopped in
complicated economic growth in the
country this is only the first
step the government says the economic
situation will start to improve in the
next few months people here are not
convinced and vow to remain ready to
fight back Thea aljas buenos
AES make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer click on the not